A lot of the conversations are about preferring other language, so it's unclear why I agree that switching languages is difficult, but it also sounds like saving C++ is near impossible. Oh, I mean, very, very simple answer about why not only I want to save C++, but everybody should want to save C++. I'm lazy. C++ has one of the largest bodies of existing written code out there. And if C++ becomes a sunset language, over time that code is going to get harder and harder to maintain, and eventually, inevitably, large amounts of, recorded on October 9th, 2023. My name is Connor, and today with my co-host Bryce, we respond to some of the comments we got on episode 150, is C++ dying?
许多对话都在讨论偏爱其他语言，所以我不清楚为什么我认同切换语言很困难，但听起来拯救C++也几乎是不可能的。哦，我是说，关于为什么不仅我想拯救C++，而且所有人都应该想要拯救C++，有一个非常非常简单的答案。我很懒。C++拥有现存最大规模的已编写代码库之一。如果C++成为一门日落语言，随着时间的推移，这些代码将变得越来越难维护，最终，不可避免地，大量录制于2023年10月9日。我叫康纳（Connor），今天我和我的联合主持人布莱斯（Bryce）一起，回应我们在第150期节目《C++正在消亡吗？》中收到的部分评论。
We chat about why C is the lingua franca of FFI target languages and more. This is great because now during the podcast I can walk around and be distracted and do all sorts of other things. I mean, we'll see. We'll see. Well, this will be a good test run. I'll let the audience know
我们聊了聊为什么C是FFI目标语言的通用语等话题。这太棒了，因为现在在播客录制期间我可以走来走去，分心去做各种其他事情。我是说，我们走着瞧。走着瞧吧。嗯，这将是一次很好的试运行。我会让听众知道的
you're testing out a new mic situation yes and it's well i'm going to explain to the audience i'm just like traveling so frequently these days going back and forth between albany and new york and then like just actually traveling on the road that i am so infrequently at my desk with my actual microphone that I just went out and bought an actual decent Rode microphone that's small that I can take when I'm traveling. Because some listeners pointed out that the audio quality of the last episode was oddly worse than the audio quality of some of our road episodes where we did have a professional. Well, just to be clear, dear listeners, the reason that we had such crispy audio quality while we were on the road is because I also have a road microphone. But that is an actual high-grade interview professional thing that you have to hold with a little stick. And that's why it sounds pretty good.
你在测试一个新的麦克风设备，是的，嗯，我要向听众解释，我最近出差太频繁了，在奥尔巴尼和纽约之间飞来飞去，然后就像是在路上奔波，以至于我很少坐在桌前用我真正的麦克风，所以我索性出去买了一个真正还算不错的罗德（Rode）小麦克风，出差时可以随身携带。因为有些听众指出，上一期节目的音频质量出奇地比我们有专业设备的那些路演节目的音频质量还要差。好吧，坦白说，亲爱的听众们，我们在路上时音频质量之所以那么清晰，是因为我也有一个罗德麦克风。但那是一个真正的高级别采访专业设备，你得用一个小杆子举着它。这就是为什么它听起来相当不错。
So wait, are you in albany right now um yes but it's albany it's not albany albany all right i apologize to our new yorkers i was just out when we were getting off track here already folks but i was just outside albany and uh should what and you didn't tell me i didn't know you were in albany i was in the adirondacks that's where i was was, folks. And when? Literally, I got back to, we are recording this, happy Canadian Thanksgiving. I'm only qualifying that because most of you will be confused, but it is the one and only true Thanksgiving. Also, we should respect the fact that it's also Indigenous Peoples Day, probably a more
等等，你现在在奥尔巴尼吗？嗯，是的，但那是奥尔巴尼（Albany），不是奥尔巴尼（Albany）[注：谐音梗]。好吧，我向纽约人道歉。我刚刚离开……我们这里已经偏离主题了，各位。但我刚才在奥尔巴尼郊外，呃，应该什么……你居然没告诉我！我不知道你在奥尔巴尼。我在阿迪朗达克山脉，各位，我当时在那儿。什么时候？字面意义上讲，我回到了……我们正在录制这个，祝大家加拿大感恩节快乐。我之所以加上这个限定，是因为你们大多数人可能会感到困惑，但这是唯一一个真正的感恩节。此外，我们应该尊重这样一个事实，这也是原住民日，可能是一个更
important day. But a lot that Bryce has to say, he's trying to interrupt me, of course. But I just got back on Sunday from a, what was it, four-day conference, invitation only. And it was fantastic. It's going to lead to one of our discussion topics. But I'll let you speak because I can tell you've got some questions and some thoughts. Well, first of all, Connor, this is the second time that you have been in my vicinity and not come to visit me. And that is not okay. So the next time I see you, I am going to sew an air tag probably into your clothes.
重要的日子。不过布莱斯有很多话要说，他当然在试图打断我。但我周日刚从一个……是什么来着？为期四天的会议回来，仅限受邀参加。太棒了。这将会引出我们的一个讨论话题。但我还是让你说吧，因为我看得出来你有一些问题和想法。嗯，首先，康纳，这是你第二次来到我的附近却不来看我。这可不行。所以下次我见到你时，我可能会把一个AirTag缝进你的衣服里。
But if you're resistant, into your skin. So that I just know where you are at all times. What you really want is to put the air tag in my carry-on, which typically goes, when I travel internationally, that typically goes with me. I did not know you were in Albany, though. It's like a, you know, several-hour drive, and I was being driven by someone else, so I did not have the ability to do a little, you know, date. I would have taken the car and come and visited you. From New York, New York? No, from Albany. Yeah yeah but i didn't know this
如果你反抗的话，就缝进你的皮肤里。这样我就能随时知道你在哪里。你真正想做的是把AirTag放在我的随身行李里，当我进行国际旅行时，行李通常是跟我一起走的。不过我确实不知道你在奥尔巴尼。那是一个，你知道的，几个小时车程的地方，而且我是由别人开车载着的，所以我没有能力去进行什么，你知道的，约会。我本可以开着车去看看你的。从纽约纽约？不，从奥尔巴尼。对，对，但我当时不知道这个。
see this is on you i did not know you were not in new york new york and that you were in albany new york so that's on you and that's not on me i'll just share my how many air tags do you think i have i don't know i guess i have zero so i'm to guess you've got like three. I have 12 air tags. Okay. Seems unnecessary. You just missed Bryce describing all his air tags. I'll be sure to speed that up because guaranteed nobody cares.
你看，这得怪你。我不知道你当时不在纽约市区，而是身处纽约州的奥尔巴尼，所以这是你的问题，不是我的问题。我来分享一下……你觉得我有多少个AirTag？我不知道，我猜我有零个，所以我猜你大概有三个。我有12个AirTag。好吧。感觉没这个必要。你刚刚错过了布莱斯描述他所有AirTag的片段。我一定得把那段加速播放，因为百分之百没有人关心这个。
I thought it was pretty interesting. So, I mean, I do have a topic. I've been trying to get you to schedule time time to chat with me for the past few days because I've been excited. I got an exciting thing. All right. We are going to reverse roles. Although having talked to two other people in your orbit about this same problem, both of them indicated that you almost certainly are going to immediately know the answer to this coding problem. And it's going to make all of my very human, relatable, bumbling around when you quiz me. It's just going to look, I'm just going to look
我觉得挺有趣的。所以，我是说，我确实有个话题。过去几天我一直想让你腾出时间跟我聊天，因为我很兴奋。我有一件令人兴奋的事。好吧。我们要角色互换了。尽管跟你的圈子里另外两个人聊过同一个问题后，他们俩都暗示你几乎肯定会立刻知道这个编程问题的答案。而且当我被你盘问时，我那种非常人性化、接地气、笨手笨脚的表现，只会让我显得……
very pathetic in comparison, I think. It's okay. And I'm just gonna look very pathetic in comparison i think it's okay and i'm excited and part of the reason you know i was unavailable was because i was abroad and uh you know i was near you you know technically we could have recorded if you buddy buddy buddy going from toronto to the northeast is not abroad. I understand you crossed an international border. That is not abroad. Here, let's just check. I want to check Albany, New York. Because I was actually, I was not in the popular spots of the Adirondacks.
相比之下，我只会显得非常可怜，我想。没关系。相比之下，我只会显得非常可怜，我想，没关系，我很兴奋，而且你知道，我没空的部分原因是因为我在国外，呃，你知道的，我离你很近，你知道，从技术上讲，如果我们……老兄老兄老兄，从多伦多去东北部可不算出国。我知道你穿过了一个国际边境。那不叫出国。来吧，我们查一下。我想查查纽约州的奥尔巴尼。因为我实际上，我不在阿迪朗达克的热门景点。
I was sort of in the south area, which I believe is pretty close to Albany. So let's actually check. For those that know, I was in the town of Indian Lake. It's the middle of nowhere, folks. Indian Lake, we've had podcasts on a walk, podcasts in a car. Soon we're going to be having podcasts at the top of mountains. And we could have had podcasts in a park. I have had a park pod on one of my other podcasts. Anyways, we will get straight into your problem after two recaps. So first things we want to mention is, well, I got to thank you personally bryce for your hot takes on episode 150 it uh as expected is trending very well statistically we've got uh we've got i've got
我大概在南部地区，我想离奥尔巴尼挺近的。所以我们来查一下。懂的人都知道，我在印第安湖镇。那是荒郊野岭，各位。印第安湖，我们做过散步播客，车上播客。很快我们还要在山顶做播客。我们本可以在公园里做播客。我在我的另一个播客里做过公园播客。不管怎样，我们将在两个回顾之后直接进入你的问题。所以我们要提到的第一件事是，嗯，布莱斯，我得亲自感谢你对第150期的犀利观点（hot takes），正如预期的那样，它在统计数据上表现非常好，我们有……我们有……我有
a lot of i wouldn't say a lot i've gotten an above average number of people dming me one person said and i believe that was also the episode where I trash talked another podcast. Yes, yes. And they caught wind. Also, I apologize for not knowing. This is kind of on Oxide. Do I have to be a guest on another podcast now? That hasn't been set up yet.
很多……我不会说很多，我收到数量高于平均水平的人给我发私信（DM）。有一个人说，我坚信这也是我在节目中痛骂另一个播客的那一期。是的，是的。他们注意到了。另外，对于不知情我感到抱歉。这有点怪 Oxide 播客。我现在必须去当另一个播客的嘉宾吗？这还没安排好呢。
But I have to apologize. But this is kind of on Oxide and Friends, the podcast. They don't go around at the beginning of each podcast recording and like say their names and introduce themselves which makes sense because it's like an open discussion which is why i don't really know the names of the characters but the person specifically that was talking with brian cantrell his name is adam leventhal i hope i'm pronouncing that correctly and he's at ahl on twitter for folks that want to go check him out is is he the one that i, uh, yes, yes. I'm sorry, man. I'm sorry. So, you know, we got a couple of people that I didn't add Adam or Brian in the tweet about the podcast, but then a couple of people in the comments added him. And then he ended up, uh, retweeting saying that it wasn't
但我得道歉。但这有点怪 Oxide and Friends 这个播客。他们不在每个播客录音开始时到处报出自己的名字并做自我介绍，这其实合情合理，因为这就像是一场开放式的讨论，这也是为什么我其实并不知道那些角色的名字，但那个具体和布莱恩·坎特雷尔（Brian Cantrell）交谈的人，他的名字叫亚当·莱文塔尔（Adam Leventhal），我希望我发音准确，他在推特上的账号是 @ahl，想去了解他的人可以去看看，他就是那个我……是的，是的。对不起，兄弟。对不起。所以，你知道的，有几个人……我在关于播客的推文中没有加上亚当或布莱恩，但随后评论区里的几个人把他们加进去了。然后他最后，呃，转发了并说这并不
very nice. I'm pretty sure he was being sarcastic because he made a joke about like, you're punching down, man. We don't even have a podcast intro jingle. So I'm pretty sure he was it was all in good fun. But we had one person DM me saying that they were pretty sure this was the end for them and they had to stop listening. Listen, folks, if you if you need to stop listening, feel free to just stop listening and not let us know. Like, we're not going to change anything because you may or may not be be upset by what we said wait wait what what was their what was their uh what was their objection would you like me i won't reveal them by name uh but i know we actually don't know is it somebody i know no no i don't think so okay but oh i'm actually going to need to go
非常友好。我很确凿他是在讽刺，因为他开玩笑说，老兄，你这是在向下重击（punching down）。我们甚至连播客开场铃声都没有。所以我很确定他这完全是闹着玩的。但我们有一个人发私信给我们，说他们确信这是他们的最后一期，他们不得不停止收听了。听着，各位，如果你……如果你需要停止收听，请尽管直接停止收听，不用让我们知道。就像，不会因为你可能对我们所说的话感到不满或不满意，我们就去改变任何事情。等等，等等，他们的……他们的……他们的异议是什么？你想让我……我不会指名道姓地透露他们……但我知道，我们其实并不知道，这是我认识的人吗？不，不，我觉得不是。好吧。但我实际上需要去
to the adsp twitter which requires me opening up Firefox because that's the only thing I use Firefox for, for folks, is not having to switch Twitter accounts on the website. I just, I keep my Firefox logged in to the ADSP Twitter account. You know, there's like on the phone, there's a very simple...
ADSP 的推特账号，这需要我打开火狐（Firefox），因为那是唯一让我使用火狐浏览器的原因，各位，就是不用在网站上切换推特账号。我只是，我让火狐保持登录 ADSP 的推特账号。你知道的，就像手机上，有一个非常简单的……
It's easy to do it on the phone. It's almost as easy to do it on the computer. But here, this is the DM that I got from an individual that might not be listening to episode 151. And they have actually messaged me in the past. Now, if they went through the trouble to send a DM, they're still listening. They're not going to be after this one. And this person in the past, they've messaged me multiple times complaining about your interrupting either guests or me. And then I've been trying to console them being like, don't worry.
在手机上操作很容易。在电脑上操作也差不多一样容易。但在这里，这是我从一个人那里收到的私信，他们可能没有听第151期节目。而且他们过去实际上给我发过私信。现在，如果他们大费周章地发了一条私信，他们其实还在听。听完这期之后他们也不会不听的。而且这个人过去曾多次发私信抱怨你打断嘉宾或我的讲话。然后我一直在试图安抚他们，对他们说，别担心。
I'm trying to keep them in line. But he's entertaining. He may ruffle your feathers, but it's kind of like being a character. Whether you tune in because you don't like them or you tune in because you do like them you want to tune in i'm definitely the bad guy of this podcast anyways this is uh this individual uh who won't be named and they write wow this latest episode is so disappointing i am 17 minutes in and i think it's the last straw for me. I feel, it feels so conservative to not listen to outside opinions, discard criticism, and almost attack a stranger for their opinions. And that's all they wrote, folks.
我会试着管好他的。但他很有趣。他可能会惹恼你，但这有点像是在扮演一个角色。不管你是因不喜欢他们而收听，还是因喜欢他们而收听，你都会想收听。我绝对是这个播客里的反派，不管怎样，这是……这个人……不会说出名字，他们写道：“哇，这最新的一期太令人失望了。我听了17分钟，我觉得这是压垮我的最后一根稻草。我觉得，不听取外部意见、无视批评，甚至几乎因为一个陌生人的观点而攻击对方，这太保守了。”这就是他们写的一切，各位。
I didn't reply, because what do you say to that? How much do you have a response, Bryce? I do think that if you listen to what I was saying, I was not rejecting outside criticism. I think I acknowledged and in fact agreed with the basic premise of what they were saying. I just disliked the way it was being expressed and felt that they were viewing C++ through a lens of like the early 2000s. Yep, fair. I mean, I think there were some spicy takes, some spicy back and forth, but honestly, I think it's all in good fun. And like I think I even said, mid-podcast, hot takes are great. You know? Nobody wants to hear a boring monotonous well, you know, it's nuanced back and forth.
我没有回复，因为你能对那种话说什么呢？布莱斯，你觉得有多少回应？我确实认为，如果你听了我当时在说的话，我并不是在拒绝外部批评。我认为我承认并实际上同意了他们所说观点基本前提。我只是不喜欢它的表达方式，并觉得他们是以一种2000年代初期的视角来看待C++。是的，很公正。我是说，我觉得有一些辛辣的观点，一些针锋麦芒的来回，但老实说，我觉得这纯粹是好玩。而且就像我在播客中间可能说过的那样，犀利观点太棒了。你知道吗？没人想听枯燥乏味、千篇一律的……你知道的，微妙的观点交锋。
It's good to have hot takes. We did also, I wasn't going to mention this, but we did get a comment from this one was a comment, so it wasn't a DM, so I can mention their name. Hopefully I'm going to pronounce this correctly, but if not, I apologize. Alexander Banduquala.
有犀利观点是件好事。我们还……我本来不打算提这个，但我们确实收到了一条评论——这是一条评论，所以不是私信，所以我可以提他们的名字。希望我的发音是正确的，如果不是，我深表歉意——亚历山大·班杜夸拉（Alexander Banduquala）。
And they wrote, would love an episode. We don't, it's not going to be this one, although we might get some brief comments if they're, you know, constrained to less than 60 seconds from Bryce, about why you want to save C++. A lot of the conversations are about preferring other language. So it's unclear why I agree that switching languages is difficult, but it also sounds like saving C++ is near impossible. Oh, I mean, very, very simple answer about why not only I want to save C++, but everybody should want to save C++. I'm lazy. And I hope everybody else is lazy too. C++ has one of the largest bodies of existing written code out there. And if C++ has one of the largest bodies of existing written code out there. And if C++ becomes a sunset language, over time that code is going to get harder and harder to maintain.
他们写道：“很想听一期节目——我们不会做这个，尽管布莱斯可能会做一些简短的评论，如果它们被限制在60秒以内的话——关于你为什么想要拯救C++。许多对话都在讨论偏爱其他语言，所以不清楚为什么我同意切换语言很困难，但听起来拯救C++也几乎是不可能的。哦，我是说，关于为什么不仅我想拯救C++，而且所有人都应该想要拯救C++，有一个非常非常简单的答案。我很懒。我希望其他人也很懒。C++拥有现存最大规模的已编写代码库之一。如果C++拥有现存最大规模的已编写代码库之一。如果C++成为一门日落语言，随着时间的推移，这些代码将变得越来越难维护，”
And eventually, inevitably, large amounts of that code will have to be rewritten entirely in a different language. And there's just no world in which that migration does not come with a grave cost. And I don't want to pay that cost. I would like the world to be able to continue using C++ code for the next 50, 60 years and have it be a healthy part of the ecosystem. I'm not saying that every new project should be written in C++. I think there are some that should be. But I don't want the existing body of code to have to be rewritten or replaced because that, uh, if we do that only because if we have to do that solely because the C plus plus language,
“并且最终，不可避免地，大量此类代码将不得不完全用另一种语言重写。没有任何世界能够让这种迁移不付出沉重的代价。而我不想支付这个代价。我希望世界能够在未来50、60年里继续使用C++代码，并让它成为生态系统中健康的一部分。我并不是说每个新项目都应该用C++编写。我认为有些项目应该用它。但我不想让现有的代码库被重写或替换，因为那样的话，呃，如果我们这样做仅仅是因为如果我们不得不这样做，纯粹是因为C++语言，”
um, has become stagnant, uh, that would be a huge waste. Um, and I, you know, you get,
“已经变得停滞不前，那将是巨大的浪费。呃，而且我，你知道的，你懂的，”
you, you, you, a lot of people get excited about like rewriting a project from scratch, like starting over. Oh, we can do everything right this time. Oh, I don't want to do that. That just sounds like a lot of work. And I would much rather work smart than hard.
“你，你，很多人对从头重写一个项目感到兴奋，比如重新开始。哦，这次我们可以把一切都做对。哦，我可不想那样。听起来有好多工作要做。我宁愿聪明地工作，也不愿辛苦地工作。”
And I think it's really good to be lazy in this field and to not reinvent the wheel. So, you know, that's why I think we should want to save C++. Because like it's here today, we have a ton of code written in it. And that code is important. Yeah. And your answer kind of highlights why three of the four main successor initiatives, although I guess you might not consider Circle a successor initiative, but it's always listed in the list. Three of them are trying to maintain a very good story for backwards compatibility.
而且我认为在这个领域保持懒惰、不重复造轮子真的是一件好事。所以，你知道的，这就是为什么我认为我们应该想要拯救C++。因为它今天就在这里，我们有大量用它编写的代码。而且这些代码很重要。是的。你的回答在某种程度上突显了为什么四个主要继承者倡议中的三个——尽管我想你可能不认为 Circle 是一个继承者倡议，但它总是被列在名单中——其中的三个都在试图为向后兼容性维持一个非常好的说法。
CPP front, basically you can just, you know, CPP2 just, or CPP front compiles to C++, everything works. Carbon has like a first class story for trying to interop and they're trying to build tools for where it won't work. And Circle is just a advanced C++ state-of-the-art compiler. I think Val, which also we got another comment. Ooh, let's bring up my LinkedIn because I'll mention them by name as well,
CPP Front，基本上你可以，你知道的，CPP2 只是……或者说 CPPfront 编译成 C++，一切都能正常工作。Carbon 有一个关于尝试互操作的一流说法，并且他们正在为无法工作的地方构建工具。而 Circle 只是一个先进的 C++ 最先进的编译器。我认为 Val——我们还收到了另一条关于它的评论。哦，调出我的 LinkedIn，因为我也要点名提到他们，
except I need to switch back to Chrome now. So I don't need to sign in. I got a comment that was, you mentioned Val, and it's no longer called Val. We need to start calling it by its real name. This was Chris Van Rens, I believe. Yes. And the new name for it is Hilo. So we're going to trip up and call it Val. And I thought about going back and renaming our episodes, because while we were talking with Sean Perrin when we were in Folkestone in the UK for CPP on C, it was still named Val. But then by the time I think some of those episodes came out or right after it got renamed to Hilo, we're leaving it as Val back there. But going forward, we will try to call it Hilo. But Hilo is really of the four of those initiatives, Circle, CPP Front,
不过现在我需要切回谷歌浏览器（Chrome）。所以我不需要登录。我收到了一条评论，提到你提到了 Val，但它不再叫 Val 了。我们需要开始用它的真名称呼它。我想这是克里斯·范伦斯（Chris Van Rens）说的。是的。它的新名字是 Hilo。所以我们以后可能会口误叫它 Val。我曾考虑过回去重新命名我们的节目，因为当我们在英国福克斯通参加 CPP on Sea 会议时与肖恩·帕伦（Sean Parent）交谈时，它仍然叫 Val。但到了其中一些节目播出时，或者紧接着它就被改名为 Hilo，我们在过去的节目里还是保留叫它 Val。但从今以后，我们会尽量称其为 Hilo。不过在这四个倡议中，Hilo 确实是唯一一个没有试图优先考虑向后兼容性的倡议。而且我仍然认为他们试图提供某种说法，比如他们会有一个，你知道的，也许是从 C++ 到 Hilo 的转换文档，但其他三个都有非常好的说法。而且部分原因，老实说，我不——我不知道这是否是——我的一部分人认为不专注于向后兼容性是个绝妙的主意。原因在于要与 C++ 兼容实在是太难了。我的一部分人认为，如果你从语言之初就不关注这一点，它就永远不会发生。但如果你从语言之初就关注这一点，那么它可能就会消耗你的全部精力，而且有一个相关的故事，我
and Carbon. Hilo is the only one that isn't trying to prioritize backwards compatible. And I still think they are trying to have some kind of story, like they'll have a, you know, maybe a from C++ to Hilo, you know, documentation, but the other three are all, all have really good stories. And a part of, and honestly, I'm not, I'm not sure if that's – part of me thinks that's a great idea to not focus on the backwards compatibility. The reason being it's real hard to be compatible with C++. Part of me thinks if you don't focus on it from the start of the language, it'll never happen. But if you do focus on it from the start of the language, then'll never happen um but like if you do focus on it from the start of the language then it it may consume your entire effort um and uh there's a relevant story that i
总是讲给雷蒙娜（Ramona）听，呃，我要把它讲出来，但我猜康纳会把它加速播放。好吧，我们需要决定，呃，我们是打算试着……你的算法问题是作为一个单独的节目，还是我们打算把它塞进这场讨论的结尾？我不知道。我让你来做这个决定。你觉得这要花多长时间？10分钟？15分钟？30分钟？哦。15、30分钟。你知道吗？
that i tell ramona all the time um uh and i'm gonna tell it but I think Connor's going to speed it up. Well, we have to decide, uh, are we going to try is, is, do you want your algorithm question to be a separate episode or are we going to try and squeeze it into the end of this discussion? I don't know. I'm going to let you make that decision. How long do you think it's going to take? 10 minutes? 15? 30? Oh. 15, 30 minutes. You know what?
我们要跳过布莱斯的故事。好吧，我们跳过布莱斯的故事。我可以不负责任。但实际上，我们刚刚在这里讨论的内容引出了一个有趣的问题，这个问题我想我以前从来没有深入思考过，但我认为是我们俩都知道千真万确的一件事，
We're going to skip the Bryce story. Okay, we'll skip the Bryce story. I can be irresponsible. But actually, what we're just talking about here brings up an interesting question which I've never, I think, thought about deeply before, but I think is something that both of us know to be true,
那就是 C++ 是一种非常糟糕的接口语言。我的意思是，对于其他语言来说，它是一种糟糕的语言，无法作为相互交互的媒介。现在，从另一方面来看，C 语言简直棒极了。C
which is C, C++ is a really poor interface language. And by that, I mean it is a poor language to be used as a medium for other languages to interoperate with. Now, C, on the other hand, is freaking great. C
是事实上的 ABI 语言。如果你想让两种不同的语言、库或事物进行交互，语言。就像如果你想写一个库，如果你想让两个不同的，你知道的，语言、库或事物进行交互，你定义一个 C API。原因有几个。第一，C 的性质意味着你不会把太多具有平台特定 ABI 性质的东西带到 API 中。我想这也暴露了更少类型系统。还有什么让 C 成为比 C++ 更好的接口语言呢？
is the de facto ABI language. If you want to have two different languages or libraries or things interact, language. Like if you want to write a library, if you want to have two different, you know, languages or libraries or things interact, you define a C API reasons for this. One, the nature of C means that you have less stuff boil up into the API that has a platform-specific ABI nature to it. And I guess also less of the type system is exposed. What else is it that makes C a better interface language
你觉得呢？我的意思是，我们知道这是事实，对吧？是的。我的意思是，它是 FFI 的通用语（lingua franca），几乎任何构建 FFI 的语言都是以 C 为目标的。我其实并不知道。
than C++? What do you think? I mean, I think we know this to be true, right? Yes. I mean, it is the lingua franca of FFI and like almost any language that builds an FFI, it's to target C. I don't actually know.
如果你看看 C++ 和 Python 之间的接口方式，它们——至少在我最后一次涉足该领域时——都糟糕透顶。我只想假设它们——你知道的，如果它们——至少在我最后一次涉足该领域时它们都糟糕透顶，我只想假设它们——你知道的，如果它们今天变得更好，可能会稍微好一点，但它们可能仍然相当糟糕，是的。而且我不是一个……确信有（我们的听众中有 10% 的人比我更适合回答这个问题），但在我的心智模型中，C 语言是一个简单得多的
And if you look at like ways of like interfacing between like C++ and Python, like they're, at least the last time I did anything in that space, they're all horrific. And I'm just going to assume that they're, you know, if they're at least last time i did anything in that space they're all horrific and i'm just going to assume that they're you know if they're better today they might be a little bit better but they're still probably pretty horrific yeah and i'm not a i'm sure there's you know 10 of our listeners are better people to ask for the answer but like in my mental model c is a much simpler
语言，并不一定……简单性就是一切。那并不一定……简单性是一点。是的，这并不一定意味着它是一门更好的语言，但它确实简单得多。比如它没有泛型或模板等效物的设施。而且 C 的演变，尽管它正在进行中，而且他们正在添加新东西，并且有一个活跃的 C 委员会，
language that doesn't necessarily simplicity is what. That doesn't necessarily... Simplicity is one. Yeah, it doesn't necessarily mean it's a better language, but it is much simpler. Like there's no facilities for, you know, generics or an equivalent of templates. And also the evolution of C, although it is ongoing and they are adding things and there is a C committee that is active,
我认为他们在所做的语言更改方面要保守得多、保守得多。这为 FFI 创造了一个更加稳定的目标，就好像如果某个东西每三年更新一次，伴随着一堆新的语言更改，比如 lambda 表达式之类的话，那么你就会听到人们说：“哦，你知道的，我希望能够以使用 X 的这个库为目标，但我现在做不到，因为我正在使用的语言的 FFI 功能不支持新的 C11 标准或类似的东西。”
I think they are much, much more conservative in the language changes that they make. And that leads to a much more stable target for an FFI in terms of like, if it's something is getting updated, you know, every three years with a bunch of new language changes in terms of like lambdas and stuff like that, then you, you're going to have people saying, oh, you know, I want to be able to target this library that uses X, but I can't do that now because the FFI capabilities of the language that I'm using doesn't support the new C11 standard or something like that.
不管那是不是真正的答案，我其实并不知道，但在我脑海里，情况就是这样。我的第一直觉也是简单性，但我怀疑其中还有更深层次的东西，因为还有其他简单的语言，对吧？呃，我是说，也许部分原因在于 C 在系统编程中长期占据统治地位，因为它是 一门简单的语言，而且因为它是平台 API 通常所用的语言，几乎每种语言都必须与它进行接口。所以它就成了事实上的标准。也许简单性并不是它赢得通用语地位的真正原因，正如你所说。
Whether or not that's actually the right answer, I don't actually know, but in my head, that's what it is. My gut reaction was simplicity too but i i suspect that there's something deeper there because there are other languages that are simple right um i mean perhaps perhaps part of it is c's dominance in systems programming for so long that um because it was a simple language and because it was the language that platform APIs tend to be written in terms of pretty much every language had to interface with it. And so it just sort of became the de facto standard. And maybe simplicity isn't really why it won as the lingua franca, as you said.
但也许这只是早期市场的统治地位。当然，如果我们谈论为什么 C++ 不是一个好的接口语言，答案就是缺乏简单性。C++ 有一个相当复杂的类型系统和模板系统。而该类型系统直接暴露在符号的拼写中，暴露在其他语言必须与之交互的函数和类型中。是的，而且为了与 C++ 对象进行接口，你必须，你知道的，你必须处理多态性，用 C++ 的多态性处理方式来与 C++ 的函数进行接口，或者更确切地说，是为了与我们在 C++ 世界中视为函数的东西进行接口，
But maybe it was just early market dominance. Certainly, I think if we talk about why C++ is not a good interface language, the answer is lack of simplicity. C++ has a fairly complex type system and template system. And that type system gets exposed directly in the spelling of symbols, in functions and in types that other languages would have to interface with yeah and like to interface to a c++ object you have to you know you have to deal with polymorphism um with c++ way of doing polymorphism to to interface with uh c++ uh functions um uh or rather to interface with what we in the c++ world would see as a function,
它可能包括同名的多个不同重载。你知道的，如果你使用的是一个没有重载概念的语言，那么每一个重载都可能是一个不同的函数。如果你使用的语言确实有某种重载概念，那么你对重载的概念可能仍然与 C++ 的重载概念不同。所以，如果你把它看作一个更简单的问题，那就是：什么是函数？
which may include multiple different overloads of the same name. You know, if you're in a language that doesn't have a notion of overloading, each one of those may be a different function. And if you're in a language that does have some notion of overloading, then you still, like, your notion of overloading may be different than C++'s notion of overloading. And so it's, like, if you look at it as a simpler question, it's like, what is a function?
在 C 语言中，这是一个非常简单、直接的答案。而 C++，我认为并没有一个简单、直接的答案。因为我们作为 C++ 程序员认为的函数，实际上可能真的是一个函数模板或一个重载函数，它在二进制 ABI 表示中会归结为多个不同的实际函数入口点，而其他语言必须与这些入口点进行交互。
In C is a very simple, straightforward answer. C++, I would argue, does not have a simple, straightforward answer to that. Because what we as C++ programmers think of as a function might actually be really a function template or an overloaded function that boils down to multiple different actual function entry points in the binary ABI representation that other languages would have to interface with.
所以缺乏简单性肯定是 C++ 不是通用语的原因，但简单性真的是使 C 成为通用语的关键因素吗？也许是 C 类型系统的性质，你拥有这些模糊大小的类型；也许是……我认为你刚才所说的是其中的一个重要组成部分，不过。就像 C 有 50 年的先发优势一样。也许像 Zig 这样的语言实际上是作为 FFI 目标的更好语言。但 Zig 是在过去 10 年里创建的。而且没有……我不知道用 C 设计或系统库设计的库的数量是多少，这些库的设计要么是因为它们几十年前就被设计了，要么是最近设计的，但它们希望成为 FFI 的良好目标。所以这就像是——富者愈富，就像他们有 50 年的先发优势一样。可能存在某些语言，或者可以设计出更好的目标语言，但它们没有 50 年的先发优势。而且它们也没有语言生态系统？这里的答案可能真的不是将 C 与当代语言进行比较，而是问问自己，如果我们把时钟拨回，回到 70 年代，
So certainly lack of simplicity is why c++ is not the lingua franca um but is simplicity really the key thing that makes c the lingua franca perhaps it's the nature of the c type system where you have these sort of fuzzy sized types um maybe it's um i think i think what you said earlier is a huge component of it, though. Like C has a 50 year head start. And maybe a language like Zig is actually a better language to target as an FFI target. But Zig is created in the last 10 years. And there's not like, I don't know what the number of libraries that are designed in C or system libraries that were designed either because they were designed decades ago, or they were recently designed, but they wanted to be good targets for FFI. So it's just like, because it's what is it like the rich gets richer, like they had a 50 year head start. And there are probably languages out there or languages that could be designed that would be better targets, but they don't have a 50 year head start. And they don't have the ecosystem of languages? The answer here really may be not to compare C to contemporary languages, but really to ask ourselves, if we turn the clock back, we go back to the 70s,
到底是什么让 C 与其当代语言相比取得了成功？具体来说，是什么让它作为系统编程语言取得了成功。这不是一个未知的被讨论过的问题。它已经被讨论过了，甚至在其他播客、其他文学作品、其他媒介中被讨论得烂熟于心。我是说，但是等等，当时其他的系统语言是什么？我不知道。我个人，我完全不知道。
what really made C successful compared to its contemporary languages? And specifically, what made it successful as the systems programming language. And this is not a question that is an unknown question. It's been talked about, perhaps even talked about to death in other podcasts, other literature, other mediums. I mean, but wait, though, what were the other systems languages at the time? I don't know. I personally, I have no idea.
我不知道，我个人，我完全不知道。我也不知道。我是说，我能想到的唯一的语言就是 Ada，而且我实际上不知道那是哪一年创建的。我可以给你报出一堆 70 年代和 80 年代其他流行的语言，比如 Smalltalk、Pascal 等等，但这些都不是系统语言。Ada 和 Smalltalk，或者说，是的，Ada 和 Smalltalk，呃，我想我们简短地聊聊那些，因为我认为 Ada 和 Smalltalk 与 C 相比有一些相似之处，好吧。我是说，它们是非常不同的语言，对吧？我不知道，是的，但是。
I don't know i personally i have no idea i don't know either i mean i the only one i can think of is ada and i actually don't know what year that was created and i can i can rattle you off a bunch of other popular languages from the 70s and 80s like small talk and pascal and etc but like none of those were systems languages ada and small talk um or sorry yeah adam and small talk um i think let's talk about those briefly um because i think they have some similarities there ada and small talk um in comparison to c okay i mean like they're very dissimilar languages though correct i don't know yeah but. Yeah, but in terms of level of complexity. Okay. They both have an object model. I know Ada does now. Did it back in the day?
是的，但在复杂性水平方面。好吧。它们都有一个对象模型。我知道 Ada 现在有。当年有吗？
I know very little about Ada other than it's one of the very few languages that has fixed point and bounded integer types as a part of their type system. I mean, Smalltop certainly was an object-oriented language from the start, right? Yes. I mean, it is. Okay. I'm fairly certain, just based on the first sentence of the Ada wiki, that it's also an object-oriented programming language from the start. Okay.
我对 Ada 知之甚少，只知道它是极少数将定点数和有界整数类型作为其类型系统一部分的语言之一。我的意思是，Smalltalk 从一开始就是面向对象的语言，对吧？是的。我的意思是，它是。好吧。我相当确定，仅根据 Ada 维基百科的第一句话，它也是从一开始就是面向对象编程语言。好吧。
Is Pascal an object-oriented programming language from the start. Okay. Is Pascal an object-oriented language? I don't know much about Pascal, other than it was one of Wirth's languages. Because isn't there object Pascal, which was a later derivative of it, specifically for object-oriented programming? Maybe. I know that Pascal led to Delphi or Delphi.
Pascal 从一开始就是面向对象编程语言吗？好吧。Pascal 是面向对象的语言吗？我对 Pascal 知之甚少，只知道它是沃斯（Wirth）的语言之一。因为难道没有对象 Pascal（Object Pascal）吗？那是它的后代派生物，专门用于面向对象编程？也许吧。我知道 Pascal 催生了 Delphi 或 Delphi。
Right. So I would say that the reason that Ada and Smalltalk probably didn't succeed as Lengua Franca. Wait, wait, wait. I got to clear this up. Is the same reason that C++ fails in comparison to C, which is that they're substantially more complex languages. And in particular, they're languages with object model um and figuring out how to uh interface to objects is harder than figuring
对。所以我要说的是，Ada 和 Smalltalk 之所以可能没有成功成为通用语（Lingua Franca）的原因——等一下，等一下。我得把这个搞清楚。——与 C++ 相比 C 失败的原因是一样的，那就是它们是复杂得多的语言。特别是，它们是带有对象模型的语言，并且弄清楚如何与对象进行接口要比弄清楚
out how to interface to simple structs and functions there's a there's a couple uh listeners that are like screaming in their heads right now because you've misunderstood what i what i said i i was rattling off a couple popular languages that would never have been the lingua franca ffi target because they're not systems like uh small talk is like a totally gc'd not the most performant message passing system that uh lives in like a workspace similar to apl that like you don't have like written text you have like workspaces that you load and so and like you can only develop in small talk in like a specific ide that's built for the language like it it would be impossible you know and i get that and i was confused where you were listening at but ada is different so yeah ada is that's but
如何与简单的结构体和函数进行接口要困难得多。现在有一些听众脑子里正在尖叫，因为你误解了我所说的意思。我刚才列举了几种永远不会成为 FFI 目标通用语的流行语言，因为它们不是系统语言。比如 Smalltalk 是一种完全带有垃圾回收机制的、不是性能最高的、依赖消息传递的系统，它生活在一个类似于 APL 的工作区中，在那里你没有书面文本，而是有你加载的工作区，因此你只能在为该语言构建的特定 IDE 中用 Smalltalk 进行开发。这根本是不可能的，你知道的。我懂，我当时搞混了你是在听哪里，但 Ada 不同。所以，是的，Ada 就是那样的，但
that was the only so i said the the only systems language that i know that might be a contender uh would be ada but like all the other languages i know wouldn't be contenders because i i don't think like a gc you know i think i think I think Pascal's actually, I think the question is really why did, because Pascal is the contemporary of C, right? I think the question is like why C, not Pascal? I mean, Pascal wasn't very popular. Like Pascal. Yeah, but why not? I mean, I'm not an expert in Pascal.
那只是唯一的……所以我说，我所知道的可能是竞争者的唯一系统语言将是 Ada，但据我所知，所有其他语言都不会是竞争者，因为我不认为垃圾回收……我想，我想 Pascal 实际上……我认为这个问题真的是为什么是 C，而不是 Pascal？因为 Pascal 与 C 是同时代的，对吧？我认为这个问题就像是为什么选 C，而不选 Pascal？我是说，Pascal 当时不是很受欢迎吗？像 Pascal 一样。是的，但为什么不呢？我是说，我不是 Pascal 专家。
We'd have to have someone on. But like the high level things that I know about Pascal or that is that it was taught a lot in schools. There were a bunch of people that really liked it. But at the end of day, from like a programming language theory point of view, like they introduced a lot of interesting concepts that then other languages adopted.
我们得请个人来聊聊。但我对 Pascal 了解的高层知识是，它在学校里被教了很多。有一群人真的很喜欢它。但归根结底，从编程语言理论的角度来看，它们引入了许多有趣的概念，然后其他语言采纳了这些概念。
But like it had these fatal flaws that made it very difficult to like build large scale programs and like really be productive in. What those are, I do not know. If you are a Pascal person, feel free to leave a comment on Twitter or a comment on our GitHub discussion in the podcast notes. But I just know that like Pascal was an interesting language. It had a certain in its heyday, a modicum of success. But no one was really surprised at the end of the day when it didn't like when it didn't like thrive. I think I could be wrong.
但它有致命的缺陷，使得构建大规模程序和真正提高生产力变得非常困难。这些缺陷是什么，我并不知道。如果你是一个精通 Pascal 的人，请随时在推特上或我们的播客说明中的 GitHub 讨论区留下评论。但我只知道 Pascal 曾是一门有趣的语言。在它的全盛时期，它曾取得过一定程度的成功。但当它没有……当它没有繁荣发展时，最终没有人真正感到惊讶。我想我可能是错的。
I'm sort of, like I said, high level from what I know. Pascal is a language I know very little about compared to small talk. Wow. I'm like at risk of offending some more of the listener. We've got to have some old person on here to teach us some things about, about the history of sea.
我有点像我说的，这只是我所了解的高层皮毛。与 Smalltalk 相比，Pascal 是我知之甚少的一门语言。哇。我有冒犯更多听众的风险。我们得请一些老一辈的人来这里教我们一些关于……关于 C 语言历史的知识。
Sure. I mean, we got to have a lot of folks on. I mean, we got a couple of comments that said you have to get Brian Cantrell on as like fast as possible. So I don't think Brian listens to this, but we will reach out to Brian. I mean, we've, I think we have a list of folks that we I mean, we still have a long list of folks from when we talked to this, but we will reach out to Brian. I mean, we've, I think we have a list of folks that we, uh, I mean, we still have a long list of folks from when we talked to, um, Jane, which was the start and then very quick end of our, us becoming a rust podcast. Um, but we were supposed to have a bunch of folks on Esteban who worked a lot on the error messages.
当然。我是说，我们得请很多人来。我是说，我们收到了一些评论，说你必须尽最大可能把布莱斯·坎特雷尔（Brian Cantrell）请来。所以我不认为布莱斯会听这个，但我们会联系布莱斯的。我是说，我们——我想我们有一份名单，里面有我们——我是说，当我们和简（Jane）交谈时，我们仍然有一份很长的名单，那是我们成为一个 Rust 播客的开始，也是非常短暂的结束。但我们本该请来埃斯特班（Esteban），他为错误信息做了很多工作。
We were supposed to have JT on to talk about, you know, the working on the community aspect of Rust and why it became super successful. Anyways, lots of folks. And we will also have someone who is a C expert and a C... I was thinking about this. Is veteran a word that you should not be using? Because I referred to... In a couple talks, I said that I referred to APL people that I chatted with as these APL veterans. And in hindsight, I was like, I probably should have just said experts. But I'm not sure. Is it on a list of words or is it okay to say veteran? It's not on the list of words that I worked on the Insights in Christian Terminology list. However, there are words in that list that are words that are recommended avoiding
我们本该请 JT 来谈谈，你知道的，致力于 Rust 的社区方面以及它为什么变得超级成功。不管怎样，有很多人。我们还将邀请一位 C 专家和 C……我一直在想这个。Veteran（老兵）是一个你不应该使用的词吗？因为我提到……在几次演讲中，我说我把我聊过的 APL 人称为这些 APL 老兵（veterans）。事后诸葛亮地想，我觉得我当时可能应该只说“专家”（experts）。但我不太确定。它是在词语黑名单上，还是说使用 veteran 是可以的？它不在我曾参与编写的《基督教术语洞察》（Insights in Christian Terminology）词汇列表中。然而，该列表中确实有一些词是建议避免使用的，
because they were military jargon or they had a military connotation. I generally think that it's best to avoid words that have any sort of military or war connotation if you can. I know that there are some people that are bothered by it. The nice thing about the word veteran is I actually think it encapsulates a certain amount of respect because you're trying to say not only are you an expert, but you're an expert that has been doing this for a long time. So it's both like experience and expertise. And I don't know, like expert covers
因为它们是军事术语或带有军事内涵。我通常认为，如果可能的话，最好避免使用任何带有军事或战争内涵的词。我知道有些人对此感到困扰。Veteran 这个词的好处在于，我实际上认为它蕴含了一定程度的尊重，因为你不仅是在说你是一个专家，而且你是一个在这个领域干了很久的专家。所以它兼具了经验和专长。而且我不知道，就像“专家”只能涵盖
60% of that. I don't think anyone is going to be like, oh, you're just calling me an expert. I would prefer you point out that I've been doing this for decades. But anyways, yeah, probably best to... I would avoid the term veteran because it does have a military connotation. However, I did take two years of college Latin and I learned very little, but very, very little. I took Latin in college because I figured it's a dead language. They can't make you speak it. Like they would make you write it, but I was like, they can't make me speak it. And I'm terrible at pronouncing things.
其中的 60%。我不认为会有人觉得：“哦，你只是叫我专家。我更希望你指出我已经从事这个几十年了。”但不管怎样，是的，可能最好……我还是会避免使用 veteran 这个词，因为它确实带有军事内涵。不过，我上过两年大学拉丁语，学到的东西非常少，真的非常少。我上大学时选修拉丁语，是因为我想这是一门死语言。他们没法强迫你把它说出来。就像他们会让你写出来一样，但我当时想，他们没法强迫我把它说出来。而且我非常不擅长发音。
I was wrong. They made me try to pronounce Latin. uh latin um i'm pretty certain that veteran comes from the latin uh the turn is the turner is something like that which is uh which means like old um uh like experienced and does not have a specific military connotation i think the origin of the word doesn't have that but since then you know culturally we we you say veteran um uh you assume that people mean uh people hear a military connotation to it so that's why we should avoid i mean i now and right after i said you know it doesn't capture the experience part um only the expert part by saying expert i, you know what I could just say? Experienced experts. That works just fine. So anyways, we got to wrap up our last, stay tuned, our few episodes.
我错了。他们让我试着发拉丁语的音。呃，拉丁语，嗯，我相当确定 veteran（老兵）源自拉丁语，那个词根大概是这样的，意思是“年长的”、嗯，比如“有经验的”，而且它原本没有特定的军事内涵，我觉得这个词的起源并没有那个意思，但从那以后，你知道，在文化上，我们——当你用 veteran 这个词时，嗯，你会假设人们会理解为——人们会听出其中的军事内涵，所以这就是为什么我们应该避免使用它。我的意思是，现在，就在我刚说完之后，你知道它没有抓住“经验”这一部分，只抓住了“专家”这一部分。通过说“专家”，你猜怎么着，我可以说什么？有经验的专家。这样就行了。所以无论如何，我们要结束我们的最后一期——请继续关注——接下来的几期节目。
There is one more thing. So we only are at point one of two points that we needed to bring up before we were to get to Bryce's algorithm. But we're at the halfway point. And we need to record two more episodes tonight because Bryce is excited about something, but I'm also excited about something. Anyways, the other thing I want to mention before we get to episode 152 is that we had someone reach out on GitHub, if I can bring up that issue. And because we're short on time, I am not going to read the whole thing. But basically, it was a response to episode 149 where we were talking about my City Strides root generation algorithm. And the GitHub user's name is CarString.
还有一件事。所以我们目前只讲了需要提出的两个要点中的第一点，然后才会讲到布莱斯的算法。但我们已经到了中点。今晚我们还需要再录制两期节目，因为布莱斯对某事感到兴奋，但我对某事也很兴奋。无论如何，在我讲到第 152 期节目之前，我想提的另一件事是，有人在 GitHub 上联系了我们，如果我能调出那个 Issue 的话。因为时间紧迫，我不会把整段都读完。但基本上，那是对第 149 期节目的回应，当时我们在讨论我的 City Strides 路线生成算法，那个 GitHub 用户的名字叫 CarString。
Let's see, if I click on this, it does have the name. The name is Chris Wesseling and they are in Amsterdam. I think actually Chris might follow me on Strava. I could be wrong about that. But I think these are the same person even though I have not made that connection. And he points out a bunch of stuff about graph theory and some optimizations.
让我看看，如果我点击这个，确实有名字。名字叫 Chris Wesseling，他们住在阿姆斯特丹。其实我觉得 Chris 可能在 Strava 上关注了我。我可能记错了。但我觉得这就是同一个人，尽管我还没有把他们联系起来。他指出了关于图论和一些优化的大量内容。
And I've also had a couple different comments from a couple different people that I know that all had some great suggestions, some about pruning, some about annealing, some about ASTAR algorithms. We will revisit the CityStride graph algorithm in the future. But the thing that I wanted to bring up is that I don't think I articulated well some of the specifics of the challenge
我还在几个不同的人那里收到了几个不同的评论，他们都提出了很好的建议，有些关于剪枝，有些关于退火，有些关于 A* 算法。我们将来会重新审视 CityStride 图算法。但我想提出的是，我觉得我没有很好地阐明我所解决的挑战的一些具体细节，
that I was solving, which led people to be kind of confused. And one of the things that I should have mentioned is when you brought up weights, I should have said that I don solving, which led people to be kind of confused. And one of the things that I should have mentioned is when you brought up weights, I should have said that, like, I don't want weights. Because weights, not only do they not help, they hurt. Because a street in this graph, one edge does not represent one street. Streets are represented by multiple edges.
这导致人们有点糊涂。我本该提到的一点是，当你提出权重时，我本应该说我不需要——我解决的问题，导致人们有点糊涂。我本该提到的一点是，当你提出权重时，我本应该说，比如说，我不需要权重。因为权重不仅没有帮助，反而有害。因为在这个图中的一条街道，一条边并不代表一条街。街道是由多条边表示的。
So you can have... it's are all edges equidistant no they all have different lengths then you want weights no let me finish my point so all i care about in my well i care about multiple things but the goal is to complete streets completing a partial street is worth nothing I do not want weights and some algorithm that rewards me for completing segments of a street or parts of a street. And also, too, you might be thinking, well, if you're completing part of a street, that's still getting you towards completing that street in the future. And the answer to that is not optimally necessarily. There are some streets... Go ahead. What do you want to say? But if it gives you a routing where... I'm gonna cut all this out probably the point is I uh this problem has been not as well articulated
所以你可以有……所有的边距离都相等吗？不，它们的长度都不同。那你要权重吗？不，让我把话说完。所以我所关心的，在我的——嗯，我关心很多事情，但目标是完成街道。完成一条街道的一部分毫无价值。我不希望有任何算法奖励我去完成街道的某个路段或街道的一部分。而且，你可能也会想，好吧，如果你完成了街道的一部分，那仍然能推动你在未来完成那条街道。而对此的回答是，不一定是最佳的。有些街道……说吧。你想说什么？但是如果它给你规划了一条路线……我可能会把这些都剪掉。重点是，我——这个问题一直没有被很好地阐明，
anyways we'll revisit the problem I will articulate it better the point is this problem has been not as well articulated. Anyways, we'll revisit the problem. I will articulate it better. The point is weighted edges, not a great idea. Be sure to check these show notes either in your podcast app or at ADSPthepodcast.com for links to anything we mentioned in today's episode, as well as a link to a GitHub discussion where you can leave comments, thoughts, and questions.
无论如何，我们会重新探讨这个问题，我会把它阐述得更好。重点是，加权边并不是个好主意。请务必查看你的播客应用中的本期节目shownotes，或访问 ADSPthepodcast.com，获取今天节目中提到任何内容的链接，以及可以留下评论、想法和问题的 GitHub 讨论区链接。
Thanks for listening. We hope you enjoyed and have a great day. Low quality, high quantity. That is the tagline of our podcast. That's not the tagline. Our tagline is chaos with sprinkles of information. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
感谢收听。希望你们喜欢，祝你们有美好的一天。质量不高，数量凑数。这就是我们播客的标语。那不是标语。我们的标语是“带有零星信息的混乱”。这期节目还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。